really succeeded in putting what he does
do alchemy internet and it's benefited a
lot of people he has a hundred thousand
subscribers on YouTube so what I'd like
you guys to do is give a huge rate is
free well just annually
[Applause]
thank you I don't know why he's talking
about the person who can find the deals
makes the most money by with the other
cash abridging partners
thank you hey what's up this is a day in
the life of so I just thought I'd give
you guys a little bit of an
behind-the-scenes look into my day so
we're in London modibo these are our
offices today's a pretty busy day I've
got back-to-back meetings with investors
businesspeople
colleagues friends potential business
ventures and they turn on speaking at
events so first meeting of the day I can
smell the success hey hey good to see
you bro thank you so much for hopping on
the train and coming down cool
[Music]
what do you think of the new unknown
tenant rights like section 20 war being
abolished well the last time uses great
really nice to summarize just connect I
think it's important normally when you
have a business meeting you want an
agenda so you meet up and you say ok
this is what I want to get how the
meeting but sometimes it's good to just
talk to people that are doing property
doing what you're doing and just touch
base your people in connect and that's
what me and Rick just did and he's doing
really well he's killing it with HMOs
and yeah nice to disconnect next we've
got a meeting with our accountants just
a regular meeting that we have every
month just to check all the everything's
in order
meeting up with the property director
Ben Mac and after that I don't even know
what's what
Karen's next up
Dinka
hey how you doing good to see ya
great to meet you hi Paul so did you say
it yeah come in yeah
yeah we're really excited yeah for sure
we just walk really good people around
this that's why we moved to London yeah
too many people like you guys yeah we
know that the best accountants are the
best lawyers best solicitors a staff are
gonna be here we get a lot of
international students coming in as well
now so we want to be central for those
guys so yeah
[Music]
so basically Jax has been having a
conversation with Patricia bright which
is awesome
how long have you followed Patricia
Brian and and it's looking fingers
crossed like we might be able to get to
the office or do some collaborations
with her yeah to do is potentially
obviously do a video on our channel but
she's very open to with her following
she likes to educate them on business
property yeah she's got like almost 3
million YouTube subscribers that's like
our channel times 30 yeah she's she's
mad she's like one of the real old G's
of you to be like churches massive so
we've got James you got you dude this is
where you got this on Jack
forgot I'm meeting with James Caan next
month yeah which is going to be again on
YouTube and I have an hour and a half
session with him potentially Patricia
bright who's next next week or the week
after yeah yeah yeah I think the thing
is when you can when you can find people
who've spent decades building their
brands to then associate with them it's
just it's just the power of branding and
that's the same as when people come on
our channel like winners Wednesday
people they were so shame with our
brands and it's just leave it's
leveraging off of off of people's brands
so as long as you share the same values
which we do with these people share the
same values have the same kind of
practices I'm really excited
well I'm not gonna get too excited you
know what
- amazing what's this stuff over here
are these like dream yeah that's awesome
man
that will happen easy-peasy that will da
yeah I'm gonna get these guys got a
meeting with Ben now yeah for sure
so basically basically Ben's directing
our property company on the commercial
side and their big thing at the moment
is the castle yeah we got Matt so
basically the gender this meeting is
going to be - we're bringing the
directors in so Russell Sarah and myself
band and we're gonna be talking about
what's happening on the property side I
think when he's setting the agenda for
last time where we said we wanted to be
yeah cool so just checking in with what
properties we've got on the table if
we've got any types of deals what you
looking at what how the castle is now in
the progression of yeah future future
opportunities in the next medium short
medium and long term ones yeah so got
some exciting things coming up over the
earth it'll be alright
these little dinky cups
[Music]
now you know honestly if you're not
embarrassed by your videos are from a
year ago then you know I'm growing
enough that honestly I look back from a
year ago and I cringe and I think good
man because he calls been are growing
good video man's me over the last four
months or you just yeah I just I don't
think it's a big deal either I also
think that it's roughly an Xterra
they're always
pray productive I think everyone can
plan page yeah hey man
Oh awesome brochure name sounds good to
me man
how did you find the crash course dude
bro do it
hey man oh man awesome ah boom
awesome stuff what's your name Christian
great to meet you buddy I'm super good
Wow apart when it comes to crash course
I like to be spontaneous good to see ya
awesome thanks for coming down bro man
I'm living London so so this what that's
what we do so did you know that the
Winston Churchill quote sorry for
writing you a long letter I didn't have
time to write your short one okay it's
brilliant it's a brilliant coy okay and
and you will have failed as I have done
fill 20 page buy-to-let application
provider let mortgage is that that's
ridiculous because you can pretty much
assess the value of a might at wallet
from the address it doesn't matter what
I have for dinner last night you know
and so what we've tried to do and we
worked it in our entire team worked on
this for about three weeks saying this
is all that we we would ideal or
theoretically need to know and then this
form which is 12 boxes long only four of
which are numbers the rest are address
in a couple of details okay and what
kind of project type it is and that's
the initial application form and that's
on our website you do that in five
minutes I thought I was the best
salesman
I don't know what's going on that's
great that's great man I appreciate your
time buddy
like really good really good thank you
thank you
yeah yeah sure Oh Darryl good to meet
you sir
great to meet you say hi it's good to be
here at by the street this is this is my
first time I don't know if you guys come
here regularly oh this is your first
time then what is my first and I've been
waiting for invitation I've been way in
he did to recall the contraband away
basically
and I was interested because the thing
is I think what he said I think a lot of
it was really good
and I actually thought wow this is great
but then at the same time I think
sometimes you can throw the baby out
with the bathwater so I messaged him
because he did you you thought known to
hide man so he kept putting lights
nightly comments on my LinkedIn stuff
he's putting little things and I saw him
so I was just like I just phoned him up
I was just like do you want to chat to
me right
you know so yeah yeah no I don't know I
really I go to every system because yeah
did you tell me you wanted me to record
the whole thing and quickly put it out
before you can put yours out no I'm just
teasing yeah I'm only teasing
okay wait the Baker Street property meat
is the bumper Edition tonight we've got
300 people in the room and it's our no
money down showdown you can watch all
these videos on our YouTube channel I'm
here with all the speakers and they're
going to tell you
a bit about what's gonna be on their
videos the best way to experience Baker
Street is actually come we meet on the
last Wednesday of every single month
with the UK's number one networking meet
you really want to come down here for
some premium networking so let's start
off with Samuel Samuel welcome to Baker
Street you're making your debut here
great this really here yeah right where
you can see you know your videos on
YouTube you're talking about no money
down residential why should people watch
that video what you're going to share
with them so the video will explain how
to buy a property without using any down
payment if you've got no money you can
still buy a residential property with
creative strategies like at least
options I think most people what they
want is they just want confirmation that
what they're doing is right so they're
about to buy a property and they're just
sort of saying oh do you think I should
do you think I should I think that's the
biggest thing it's almost self doubt and
just wanted me to just confirm that
they're doing the right thing by being a
property investor that's probably the
biggest things I think people should be
asking for connections Sam you can you
connect me to because at the end of the
day the reason that people have
obstacles is because they don't know the
right people
so just asking people like me you well
networks who do you know who can do this
who do you know who I think that's what
I'd be asking the biggest misconception
around property investing is that when
there's a recession you shouldn't wait
because people make the most the most
money in in a crash hey how you doing
Monday yeah good for you
yeah I love those everything you saw in
the crash course you reveal have you
been to a crash course yes
how was it it was amazing good stuff
thank you I actually got some of people
I met on the crash was to come here Wow
amazing really succeeded in putting what
he does do out on the internet and it's
benefited a lot of people and he has a
hundred thousand subscribers on YouTube
so what I'd like you guys to do is give
a huge basis free welcome to Samuel
leagues
[Applause]
thank you the registers have not been
investing too long I mean jeez I've been
investing a long time for me I'll bet
I've been I bought my first house on our
79 our 28 so I've been investing just
over a decade last year I bought a
castle ain't no money down Castle you
know so so if your steps could have
unknowingly down yes it works I think
that's why they've got three of us up
I'm doing no money down deals regularly
residential we've got three speakers all
about normally down so just out of
curiosity if you've ever bought a house
about using any of your own money just
raise your hand all right not not many
like mostly my students they ten people
okay if you'd like to buy houses in none
of em anyway found its way here all
right as I enjoy exposing the mix and
the banks the education systems and the
schools that teach get a job work our
health mortgage that's self so I'm glad
you're here thanks for listening or
looking for Q&A and if you want to self
if we later on I'm around all you want
chat I'll stick around and place up
didn't have a man joining the team thank
you yeah are you gonna just abandon me
now hey Hayden Brock good to see you
great to see you Philip oh yeah
I appreciate that I didn't crash it
Samia from Glasgow yeah okay yeah you
can do that finally my phone I'm on
Rightmove and Zoopla on gumtree okay
the trick is nope nope so first thing I
find a qualified address so I going
right move and I'll find properties
where the mortgage is bigger than the
value and you can do that by finding out
how much they paid for it back in
2007-2008 whatever they bought it how
much they pay for it
how much are they advertising it for now
and if they paid for it a lot more than
they're selling it now and they're going
to be a negative equity you know well in
an ideal world you take over the
mortgage payments so be like me same to
you can you pay my mobile phone bill and
then you'll take over the account is
they will usually now if they're not
then you'll reimburse him he just be
good but if you do that you want to see
quarterly statements to make sure he is
paying it so either way but if you just
need to make sure because otherwise if
he doesn't pay it and you don't know and
then the house was repossessed you've
got an interest in the house yeah
so in your situation if you're wanting
to refinance it the only way you're
going to know the figure is by getting a
a lender a bank probably through a
mortgage broker to value the house and
say here's my house how much you bought
how much you pay for 2007 say while
dying three skill sets you think we
should have to negotiate no money down
to us okay number one is you need to
know how to sell
I think sales is a very very important
skill sewed up in the first one number
two in the Goshen is is you've got to be
able to put yourself in someone else's
shoes
so sometimes rather than trying to get a
deal trying to make money trying to get
deal that we like with lease option
agreements I've never secured a lease
option agreement without first just
giving them advice telling them to keep
it telling them to rent it out
themselves and then when you exhaust the
options and you put yourself in their
shoes and you've tried to help them and
then you're gonna get the deal so being
able to sell being able to empathize and
put yourself in someone else's shoes you
know the third one is due diligence just
knowing how to work the basic maps and
what's the rent going to be what's the
you know I'm not I've never been not
amazing at maps but I know how to work
out the return on investment of a deal
really a great day it's been a started
first meeting with about 10:00 a.m. it's
now 10:00 p.m. there's been a 12-hour
day but you know what financial freedom
does not necessarily mean relaxing on a
beach like I'm financially free but that
that means that I have the time to do
things that I'm really passionate about
and that I really love doing which is
why I love speaking at programs I love
speaking events I love meeting people I
live grow my portfolio I'm not thinking
about my my freedom I'm nothing about
other people's freedom I'm thinking
about a legacy for my children and my
grandchildren and it's been a fantastic
day so meeting with the accounts sorting
out all the tax affairs to make sure
that we're saving money as well as
making money meeting with different
people collaborate on ideas fantastic
day typical day in the life of me so I
hope you enjoyed it subscribe and come
start see you next time
[Music]